the obvious career possibility so we all
have a move that probably makes squiggly
sense when I was at Microsoft as my
manager's job like that's what people
thought I should do and it seemed
sensible to do now I run my company the
sensible move for me to make is actually
just stay in my job because it's growing
my company's growing and so I will grow
with it that's the sensible move for me
to make the reason I want people to
explore this one a little bit more is
because a lot of people assume that
because it's obvious it's the right move
for them to make so they take on their
manager's job or they go for that
promotion because they've they're
currently a junior and they should be a
senior and all those kind of things all
right just stay in my role because it's
obvious that it's growing and I should
stay in it and actually maybe that role
doesn't actually need what you want to
be known for but after strengths may be
that role doesn't align with the things
that really drive and motivate you back
to your values so it'll be a good fit
for you if it fits with your values and
strengths if it doesn't then it might
look good on paper but it's not going to
be good for you